[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Coupee HD here
and this is your first look at the brand
new LG g7 thinkyou now that whole long
new name LG G 7th in queue is kind of
terrible in my opinion so I'm just gonna
call it LG g7 for the rest of this video
and probably forever so I'd actually
described this g7 kind of like a V 30
but updated for 2018 so if you don't
know if you're a member of the LGV 30
one of the most underrated phones of
last year basically this feels like a
very reactive phone in 2018 meaning it
doesn't really do anything new that we
haven't seen before but a lot of the
things it does it has its own little LG
twist on it so on the outside is looking
familiar right this one's silver but
there will be four colors it's glass on
the back and then aluminum around the
rails yes it does have wireless charging
and yes it is really reflective but not
as bad as some others the biggest
difference is now it actually has a real
power button on the right side instead
of just using the fingerprint reader on
the back as a power button and on the
other side you'll probably notice the
volume rocker and then a weight look
another button that is the Google
assistant button huh now that's
interesting that's actually I'm
surprised is the first time we've seen a
dedicated button for Google assistant in
a phone
not counting the squeeze feature of the
pixel that's not a button so you can
press it to open the assistant or hold
down and it'll it'll let you ask certain
things with custom voice commands kind
of like a walkie-talkie but that's all
this button does so it's kind of like
the galaxy s 9s bixby button but better
because it's Google assistant but here's
the thing I didn't just roast the bigsby
button because bixby is bad it was
because the button also wasn't
remappable it was either on or off you
couldn't make it do anything else this
Google assistant button on the g7 is
also not remappable and I have to stay
fair and say you should also be able to
remap that button not just because it's
an assistant button because it's an
extra button on a phone you should be
able to whatever you want with it so
you'll be able to enable it or disable
it through the software but no one wants
a useless extra button on their phone
when it's disabled so I encourage LG to
allow us to remap it
to a custom software button you can push
your software upgrade that lets us do
that take the lead on this one be the
people's champ any way around to the
back the cameras orientation for the
dual cameras is now vertical very 2018
putting dual cameras like this but they
still keep the flash and the laser
autofocus outside of the camera module I
kind of like it better when they put
everything inside the same module but
that's just me it feels cleaner that way
either way g7s camera bump is really
small it's in the middle of the phone
it's not bad and on the cameras
themselves might be the standout
distinguishing feature of this phone so
- 16 megapixel cameras and eff 1.6
aperture and the one is still a super
wide angle instead of a telephoto so LG
sticking to their guns this year but
this time it's a slightly less extremely
fisheye still wide angle though no photo
or video samples with the final software
available yet though that's something
we're gonna have to test for the full
review and that goes along to say - with
things like battery life on that 3000
milliamp hour battery and just general
performance through LG's software on top
of Android Oreo but I think we kind of
know what we're getting ourselves into
here with snapdragon 845 and 4 gigs of
ram it's probably pretty good
so g7 is taking all the boxes it's built
well it's ip68 water-resistant it has a
micro SD card expansion slot if you look
at the bottom of the phone yes it
absolutely still does have the headphone
jack backed by that impressive 32-bit
quad act so LG stays committed to that
premium audio experience and that little
speaker down there it looks the same but
they are much louder LG says it's about
40% louder from hearing it I'd say it's
definitely a lot louder but what's
actually more interesting is you can
feel it vibrating and moving the whole
phone the speaker uses some of the space
inside the phone and it acts as a
literal resonance chamber and you can
actually put your hand up at the bottom
of the phone and feel air moving out of
it which is really impressive but also
just holding it it's vibrating your hand
it's actually pretty cool so filling the
bass actually move air from a phone is
impressive but the sad part is there's
no stereo speaker action happening so
this tiny speaker grille is it and it's
really easy to block accidentally sadly
but then this main attraction of the
phone is up at the front it's got the
display a 6.1 inch 31 20 by 1440 IPS
display with a notch
this one's interesting it's a big
display with small bezels obviously so
that's great for 2018 there's a bit of a
small chin more than some other phones
but not so big that it's like a huge
problem for me but the interesting part
of their choice is to go with an LCD
panel instead of an OLED the biggest
benefit to this was they're super bright
mode there's a little toggle and the
brightness slider which is basically
when you're outdoors you can boost up
this displays brightness by a lot and I
can definitely say it's effective
Samsung also kind of has something like
this and it's also an OLED display but
nobody can do panels quite like
Samsung's so as long as what LG is doing
here is effective I don't mind it works
I got to use this one outdoors for a bit
as you can tell and it looked pretty
good to me
it's also colorful it's definitely sharp
and it gets bright and it has this nice
little notch up at the top just in time
for 2018
LG in the settings calls it a second new
screen for some reason not really sure
why but there's the software feature
that lets you hide the notch of course
if you're not into that but then also
even decorate it a bit if you want to
but then you can just see the notch
again so I don't really see a point to
doing that but the bottom line is it's
here
Android P when it comes out will have
some other apps working better with the
knotch I suspect that before it happens
this one will have some problems the
same way the Huawei P 20 and other early
Android phones with notches did but that
just about covers it for the hardware
like I said pretty familiar to the V 30
but a lot of the other new
differentiating things with this phone
or of course in the software department
and a lot of them have to do with you
guessed it AI it kind of feels like this
point like it's a buzzword that
everyone's throwing around everyone's
got some new AI feature in their new
phone but it is here so the main place
will see it in this g7 is the camera now
in the camera app there is a portrait
mode button and there's also this huge
new AI cam button so if you open that up
you'll get this different mode that
identifies and recognizes up to 18
different situations similar to what we
saw with the P 20 so it has a pet mode
of food mode a sunset mode of fruit mode
all that stuff I'll have to play with
amore to see how it actually adjusts the
photos once it identifies what it's
taking a picture of but one thing it
does is sometimes suggests four filters
based on what mode it's in that you
might like based on what's in the photo
I don't know it seems like very early
like no one really knows exactly what
they want to do with AI and the camera
but that's what it's doing now oh
there's also a new super bright camera
mode which kind of acts like a knight
mode and other cameras really brings up
writer exposure in nighttime or dark
shots and crossing my fingers that works
well and there's a portrait mode on both
the back facing and front facing cameras
with adjustable blur which is cool but
of course all this will have to be
tested for the full review and I think
this will be a real interesting phone
when it actually does come out a lot of
this feels similar and familiar to
people who have owned LG phones if
you've owned an lg phone before this
will be right at home even if you've
owned a Samsung before with all the
features they pack in in the settings
it'll feel right at home plus a notch it
feels like LG's biggest challenge is
standing out from the pack in some way
none of the features are really went
over in this video about this new phone
kind of let's break it away from the
pack and give you a reason to get this
phone over galaxy s 9 or even pixel two
or iPhone or whatever it's still
definitely unique with the wide-angle
camera lens I'll give it that and having
a headphone jack with the quad DAC
that's pretty unique but outside of that
you know it's pretty tough I think this
phone is probably gonna fly under the
radar again we'll see but let me know
what you think now that you've seen LG
g7 is this enough to sway you and maybe
move to it over another phone or is it
just kind of blending in the way it is
for me right now let me know if you
think in the comments below either way
thanks for watching talk to you in the
next one peace